>>Holly: The objectives for this
lesson are to understand the concepts
of water scarcity and
water shortages.
>>I'm Holly Mortimer.
I live in Boise, Idaho, and
I teach high school online
for three different schools,
and I work from home.
>>I get up about 6:45, 7:00, and
I make coffee and get my son up
and get him going, get him
ready and then start working.
>>Hey, Beckett, you need to go
play somewhere else right now.
Thank you.
>>I usually start with a school and
I respond to all my e-mail, grade,
prep for a lesson, and the other
thing that I kind of struggle
with is the days when you're all of
a sudden like, "It's five to three
and I'm still in my pajamas and
I haven't brushed my teeth yet."
>>So we start Module 8 this week.
>>So I have a broad
range of students.
I have some athletes, kids who
weren't in school last year,
students who are at risk.
>>And I want you to draw a line
to how much water you think
it takes to produce that item.
>>The key shift for an online
teacher is to go from the paradigm
of thinking about what you're
going to teach and how you're going
to teach it to, what
are the kids learning
and how are they not learning
and how are they not engaged?
It totally shifts from the
content to the student.
>>Jessie, it looks
like you're typing.
Do you have a question?
>>The way that you engage the
kids is by prompt feedback.
When they reach out to
you, you got to grab them.
At iSucceed, we have a pretty high
expectation for rapid turnaround
of grading, and they quickly become
really kind of addicted to that,
so super-prompt response when they
reach out, immediate if you can,
definitely within 24 hours.
I mean, that's how you are
there in the classroom,
and if you're not responding
promptly, they just feel
like they're in the wilderness.
>>So you should be seeing
an MP4 file loading,
and I'll put the link in the chat.
>>As an online teacher, your level
of accountability is much higher.
You're not only accountable at
the end of every testing cycle.
We have different grade
metrics, lots of different ways
that we measure them, and there's
a lot of data, a lot of data.
From my perspective, I kind of have
a bring-it-on attitude to that.
>>The key is not how
much water there is
but that it's predictable,
so in some places of...
>>If really what you love about
teaching is creating curriculum,
displays in your classroom,
designing lessons, designing tests
or assessments, it's
not the place for you,
because that is what
has been done for you.
>>Well, I think I would
put it into a chart.
>>But if you're the person who really
enjoys kind of the encouragement,
the "come on, I know you can do
this," the cheerleading aspect
of teaching, working
with the student,
really seeing clearly
their progress...
>>Good.
>>And being really
involved with the students,
then it's a great choice, because
that's what you'll be doing.
I think if there's an isolation
professionally, it's counterweighted
with the opposite of
isolation for my family,
because I'm always here,
so I see my husband.
We have lunch almost every day.
We're just all more present
together, so I'm less isolated
from my family, and
it makes up for it.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to edutopia.org.